[Music]
I've never worn matching costumes I
think this is the first time I'm
celebrating Halloween last year was her
first Halloween put a dress on her she
would she got off in approximately 30
seconds we put her in a little Halloween
costume and have her greet
trick-or-treaters she's a rescue story
or I guess I'm a rescue story and all of
this fur are just first sprinkled for
everybody
[Music]
so I'm going to draw out of here what my
costumes gonna be see lilo and stitch
holy hound and naughty nun haha king
crab and mermaid princess my the mermaid
princess we the most covered up I've
ever been in my entire life
oh my god Jolene you look so cute
hi sweetie this is the cutest thing I've
ever seen
I guess you're already surfing had you
served me I don't know why her boobs are
on her back that's weird it's hard to
find plus-sized costumes for cats
nowadays I think there's an initiative
to keep cat skinny she's the kitty with
curves
it was costumes just a little bit snug
on her this costume is a good weight
loss plan I've already lost three pounds
I feel like we look really cool I would
totally wear the costume out with my cat
matching costumes it can come off as
borderline creepy I think